let's check in with jared greenberg
a performance for the ages tonight by
kevin durant nice to see you again kevin
you said that the other day you're ready
to adapt to any situation
how much of that included preparing for
playing
every minute of tonight's game i mean
i wasn't planning on playing every
minute but as the game started to flow
we got down i told coach that uh
you know if he needed to take me out for
a couple it's cool but i feel good and
he just let me write it out so you know
jeff green was
incredible tonight james coming out here
and and and thugging it out for us
um creating being another bar handler
for us i mean i just think the second
half we played extremely hard
well that's what i wanted to ask you
about next you were amazing
in the second half but what was the this
halftime speech like from coach nash
that flipped the switch for you guys
well
just continue to just keep playing
defense because our shots wasn't falling
we were getting good looks we were
rushing a lot on offense too we were
trying to
you know get everything back so fast
being down 10 or 12 points and i think
we just settled in and
got good shots and we made some shots
too you know you got to you know guys
came in and knocked down some shots in
that third blake
jeff landry so you know we moved to
basketball like that we uh we put
ourselves in that position
well i asked two real questions so i'm
gonna end on a high note with you there
kevin
that's it all right that's it that's all
i appreciate it thank you kevin
all right thank you jared so durant 49
points 17 rebounds
10 assists he talked about jeff green's
performance
a playoff career high for jeff green 26
points
hits seven of eight from three-point
range
and the nets end up shooting 49
from the field james hart went 46
minutes just one pretend for the field
but he hung in there
with that straight hamstring had five
points
and uh he had
eight assists six rebounds